the son of famous amos is revealing
details from his adventurous childhood
in a new kids book famous amos cookies
quickly became a household name after
founder wally amos opened the first
chocolate chip cookies tour in 1975. now
wally's son sean helped create the shop
on a corner of sunset boulevard in
hollywood shawn amos's new book cookies
and milk is based in part on his
experiences growing up as the son of
famous amos first on cbs mornings we are
joined by sean who's an author and he's
also a pretty darn good musician
welcome to the show thanks for having me
i just have to tell you like i am a
legitimate like
famous amos cookie buyer legitimately
get it from my grandmother it was like
she would eat them out in a single day
so congratulations on that congrats on
the fact that you wrote this book but
you talk about so much of your childhood
being
opening this cookie store and how it was
the sheer essence of delight for you it
was joy i mean it's a book about joy you
know it's a book about fathers and sons
who want to be seen
by each other and from the world and
that was the spot where i felt i was
really seen by my father you really seen
by him yeah yeah yeah i was a divorced
kid and uh the rest of my life was
tumultuous but in that store it was just
pure joy i was sort of inoculated from
all the other stuff that was going on
what was your job in the store oh i had
every job
so i i paid i worked the front he worked
the back so i started milk crates worked
the cash register sold the cookies up
front we had a big scooper things were
like a few bucks a pound and he'd be in
the back baiting him but i would help in
the back sometimes and bake now you're
the main character is named after your
son
ellis
you also added in something personal
which is
the character being upset with his
parents because of a divorce you
recently got divorced i did yeah why put
that in the book
because it's so personal
that was the reason for writing the book
you know there's this legacy of divorce
that exists in my family i was hoping i
could beat it i didn't uh i became
estranged from my son a bit in the way
that was estranged from my father wow so
there's this you know this
pattern going wow that um that i found
myself a part of and i was so it's
therapeutic yeah i want to work that out
you know i wanted to work that out and i
wanted to give my son something some
insight of me yeah that that you could
hold on to beautiful speaking of the
father-son relationship your father is
suffering from dimension yeah um the
book the book really connected for him
because you said not only were you
writing it for yourself your son but for
your dad but he's actually
been read the book yeah yeah he's read
some chapters and uh i write in the
forward to the book you know the book is
sort of a bridge between
you know my son my father and and and me
and that's awesome in reality the
stories opened in 1975 i set the book in
76 to take advantage of some
bicentennial teams right and so what was
his response to that he's like shawn you
got the year wrong
those have dementia he remembers that
i'm like well okay there's clarity
everywhere you said the top i think the
books about joy
oh yeah yeah so what do you want young
readers to take away from it other than
joy i guess joy is a good thing to leave
for sure yeah for sure i wanted to be
curious about themselves and curious
where they come from uh and curious
about their parents yeah i i think we
keep our heads down a lot
and and we
don't look very far in the future in
back of us to for clues uh i also write
that you know there's clues everywhere
right and so if you're looking to
discover who you are and find your your
mojo um there's clues all around you you
know and they could be your father and
they can be in in your via family
history or they could be in things that
you know turn you on so that's awesome
yeah well that is awesome hopefully you
can still bake a mean cookie it's shawn
amos i'm sure oh no
cookies be happy yes cookies and milk is
on sale now we'll be right back sean
thank you that's awesome